what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we just got out
of the premiere for the movie light
year john i picked up one of these two
at the after party i gave mine away to a
little kid who wasn't able to get one i
took mine from a little kid who was so
all these people who think john's nicer
than me no i'm just getting away more
humble and i think it shows
your humbleness is off the charts right
now my guy it's been a while since we've
seen like one of the trailers for this
film but i was really much looking
forward to it now i want to get this out
of the way there's a lot of things that
people debate about this one thing to
debate is should you guys hit the like
button on this video yes you absolutely
should i definitely think you should
help us out in the algorithm secondly
what exactly is this movie is it a
prequel is it based off a real life
astronaut i feel like i've always had it
right and john's had a very different
point of view again john i'm much more
humble than you to say that i was right
can you please tell me what it was
because i still don't know this movie
makes it abundantly clear at the very
top of the film this movie could have
saved us a lot of confusion putting it
in the trailer there i know it's really
the literal first thing on screen
universe is the context basically what
they set up is that there is a movie
that andy watched that is about buzz
lightyear and then the toys that you
watch that he plays with with buzz
lightyear and zerg and all that that is
based off of the movie that andy watched
so it's like an in-universe film that
you're watching with that in mind i i
was kind of wondering very early on it
took a little bit of adjusting could i
really get into this movie though
because it made me so aware at the very
top that this is a fake piece of fiction
this is a movie i know that sounds silly
and stupid because toy story is
obviously a piece of fiction but this is
a movie within a franchise yeah yeah and
it's it's drawing attention to itself
that this is not real maybe the stakes
won't feel real but i gotta say that i
really think this movie actually very
much delivered so this film in a lot of
ways is a big blend a splice of a whole
bunch of different space sci-fi opera
films that you've seen before things
like interstellar gravity star trek star
wars 2001 a space odyssey alien the best
way i can describe the way they handled
this space sci-fi genre was the way i
felt with incredibles how they did the
superhero genre pixar of wow they
managed to do like a great animated
medium version of a superhero genre and
do things that you couldn't normally do
in a superhero film i thought that they
did that here but also keeping it very
family friendly and at times heart
wrenching but always full of wonder a
lot of existential themes we'll get into
the plot in a little bit you want to
tell them i imagine do we echo the same
i think we do yeah we want to tell what
the plot of this movie is actually about
the plot of the movie within the movie
yes within the movie basically buzz
light you're the titular hero is on a
mission to fix a mistake he made that
basically strands all of star command or
at least his unit on this desert planet
that is very hostile and then from there
beyond that come zerg and other threats
to deal with he has to challenge himself
as well as his young group of cadets to
rise to the occasion and save the day
and hopefully complete the mission get
everybody back home yeah you know in the
movie interstellar movie's a few years
old so slightly ruining the plot of
interstellar for you guys what is that
version of time travel called uh time
not dilation time dilation this time
dilution yeah where if you're traveling
at a different rate in time time moves
differently for you than it does for
other people yet that painful experience
of oh my god i i've missed out on a few
years although my loved ones around me
have aged and the trailers do show that
that is what he goes through in this
film one thing i thought that was so
wonderful about this film of how they
capture their characters is that so much
of the way the plot unfolds is the
protagonist making just
human errors human mistakes from trying
to do the right thing yeah it's always
that one little thing you missed yeah
it's not just with buzz lightyear uh who
by the way is is great in this film i
think chris evans did an exceptional job
at capturing the essence that we knew
and loved from what tim allen did with
the toy version of buzz lightyear but he
truly makes it his own like it's very
easy to distinguish the two of them and
the fact that they do space travel in
here my mind did drift off for a split
second going oh man because he did some
like weird multiverse thing where he
goes to the real world
right where he goes into like andy's
world specifically than our real world
like buzz lightyear from toy story
tim allen shows up yeah i think that
would be a really awesome film and i i
do think that he did such a great job
here a big part of what they set up with
his character is his struggle to be able
to cooperate and work with others his
ability to accept help feeling like he
always has to kind of do everything on
his own he has trust issues not that
they really dive into the background of
that but that is such a core essence of
this character and i think it's another
movie that's great for the family and i
think easily
easily the standout character though we
haven't even discussed it but i'm just
going to throw you know who is it it's
it sucks sock out of me sucks
yeah the most adorable supporting
character and i mean disney pixar they
are known for these kinds of marketable
supporting characters but hey they knock
it out of the park again socks is so
much fun a very useful character but
also a character with a huge amount of
personality and really rounds out the
ensemble for sure usually a bit cynical
whenever a character like that shows up
at first like oh here we go the toy yeah
it's like literally a cute merchandise
it's a robotic cat so i'm like you've
designed merch now to sell
congratulations disney and as i say
cynically while attending your premiere
thank you mickey mouse
easily like the crowd you could tell
just fell in love with this character
and it was seriously the best part of
the film i i actually would be like no
yeah sucks was the best part of the
movie to me
yeah there's a in a movie filled with
good stuff and a lot of great uh really
enjoyable characters and voice
performances yeah i mean socks is a
scene stealer absolutely and as you see
in the trailer again
i'm referencing the trailer has to make
sure not to spoil because there's a lot
of big plot things in this movie that
are not revealed in the trailer in the
trailer as you see that when you start
this movie off with buzz lightyear uh
his partner space ranger hawthorne is
his partner his best friend and then as
he gets a little bit more into the
future now he's dealing with the
granddaughter he's the granddaughter
played by kiki palmer both kiki palmer
or he's only the granddaughter kiki bomb
uzo duba i believe is alicia the
grandmother his best friend and then
yeah kiki palmer is uh her granddaughter
izzy well both characters are wonderful
it's the really great move to me yeah
there are all sorts of reasons people
roll their eyes like oh yeah spunky
young female astronaut or whatever but
yeah like their friendship was so
endearing and tangible and then the
relationship that unfolds with izzy the
granddaughter and you know the more sort
of workplace struggles that they face as
they try to solve these intergalactic
problems set before them yeah like
there's a lot of really wonderful growth
there are moments especially featuring
those characters in their relationship
to buzz that made me emotional and made
me tear up even during scenes that were
also involving action and you know heavy
stakes and whatnot i mean i'm glad you
brought the action because this is some
of the best action pixar has done it's
like do i think that the fight scenes
are as good as the incredibles i
wouldn't necessarily say that but it's
very different it's it's all sci-fi
space stuff you know bugs aliens lasers
a lot of great camera movements i would
say that this is one of the more intense
pixar movies there are sequences in here
that are just flat out suspenseful and
you do get that
awe-inspiring space travel experience
and it's pretty existential film you
know yeah it manages to do what i think
a lot of great space travel sci-fi even
action sci-fi movies do while never
feeling like it's pandering too young
and never feeling like it's aiming way
above anybody like it really has yes
some sci-fi themes some existential
themes a lot of great character humor
and beats and a you know big high
concept story yeah yeah it's not like
the more reflective sci-fi thing that
wall-e was which but it's got shades of
that it's got no that's i mean it has
like contextual exploration of those
things but the the vibe is very space
adventure yeah absolutely and i think
they do a really wonderful like this is
out of a pixar movies and b just
animated movies right now this was the
most i sort of lost the line between
watching an animated film and watching
just a live-action movie like even just
the melding of chris evans voice with
the animation of that character but even
further you mentioned like the camera
work and i know there's been a big
debate in movie culture recently about
how do we credit cinematographers in you
know these big cg movies because people
think oh it's just effects animators but
no like cinematography is a huge part of
it and there's so many really amazing
camera choices lens choices lighting
choices that really bring this to life
and make you feel like you're watching a
real movie which is a weird thing to say
because it is a real movie but yeah it
makes you feel like you're watching a
live action movie and you exist in the
animated realm needless to say like the
music is also great
i think there's a couple of supporting
characters that took a little bit of
time for me to warm up to but eventually
you do and uh yeah i don't really have
an issue with this film i'd actually say
i want to watch this again on imax yeah
and i could have watched it for for 10
or 15 minutes longer and this is the
first time in a long time i thought i
want to see that in 3d yeah there's some
really great scope well guys the film
delivered don't know what else to say
thank you guys so much for being here
because yeah this was uh absolutely fast
thank you guys subscribe click that bell
and we'll talk to you guys soon
lance door
door buddy listen man
we asked each other
who would we want to go to space with
and you know what we decided
who our patreon would be fun to go to
space with lance
tell them why john lance oh my god in
space where clearly strength means
everything you would be the person to
command our intergalactic mission we
would go to infinity and beyond because
of your
leadership lance door leadership you
would not make any mistakes
whatsoever and that's what i love about
you
is just your unhuman levels of
perfection lance i just want you to know
how much i hold you on this pedestal
alright space the wonders of the cosmos
screw all that buddy all right it's all
about that beautiful
tanned canadian i know called lance
canadians in space
space canadians
and the uh the the world of the great
white beyond
uh yeah man so hey he's if he's a
fighter now he could be a firefighter
maybe a space fighter
how cool would lance look putting out a
fire in some kind of like spaceship
corridor yeah
yeah it would be cool it'd be sexy it
must be a great way to get away from
that family once and for all yeah all
right lance in space no one can be like
hey
what about us
your life yeah rocks
best ass restaurants
provide for us and be emotionally
stories of people being like i got to be
away from my family this heartbreaking
but what if there was a story about one
who was like i'm going to seriously get
away much better
i didn't even want to go to space but
now that i'm up here i don't have to
talk to any of those people
a few lamps
[Music]